the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hello everybody before we start the
material a couple of announcements as
usual there's some reading assignments
and you might be surprised to see
something from Chapter five suddenly
popping up but this is my relentless
attempt to introduce more Python will
see one new concept later today list
comprehension today we're going to look
at classification and you remember less
on Monday we looked at unsupervised
learning today we're looking at
supervised learning it can usually be
divided into two categories regression
where you try and predict some real
number associated with the feature
vector and this is something we've
already done really right back when we
looked at curve fitting linear
regression in particular it was exactly
building a model that given some
features would predict a point in this
case it was pretty simple it was given X
predict Y you can imagine generalizing
that to multi dimensions today I'm going
to talk about classification which is
very common in many ways more common
than regression for in the machine
learning world and here the goal is to
predict a discrete value often called a
label associated with some feature
vector so this is the sort of thing
where you try and for example predict
whether a person will have an adverse
reaction to a drug you're not looking
for a real number you're looking for
will they get sick won't they will they
not get sick maybe you're trying to
predict the grade in the course
ABCD and other grades we won't mention
again those are labels so it doesn't
have to be a binary label but it's a
finite number of labels so here's an
example to start with we won't linger on
it too long this is basically something
you saw
in an earlier lecture where we had a
bunch of animals and a bunch of
properties and a label identifying
whether or not they were a reptile so we
start by building a distance matrix how
far apart they are
and in fact in this case I'm not using
the representation you just saw I'm
going to use the binary representation
as Professor Grimson showed you and for
the reasons he showed you and if you're
interested I didn't do produce this
table by hand I wrote some Python code
to produce it not only to compute the
distances but more in more more
delicately to produce the actual table
and you probably find it instructive at
some point to at least remember that
that code is there in case you need to
ever produce a table for some paper in
general you've probably noticed I spent
relatively little time going over the
actual vast amounts of codes we've been
posting that doesn't mean you shouldn't
look at it in part a lot of it's there
because I'm hoping at some point in the
future we'll be handy for you to have a
model on how to do something all right
so we have all these distances and we
can tell how far apart one animal is
from another now how do we use those to
classify animals and the simplest
approach to classification and it's
actually one that's used a fair amount
in practice is called nearest neighbor
so the learning part is trivial we don't
actually learn anything other than we
just remember so we remember the
training data and when we want to
predict the label of a new example we
find the nearest example in the training
data and just choose the label
associated with that example so here
I've just drawn a cloud of red dots and
black dots I have a fuchsia colored X
and if I want to classify X as black or
red I'd say well its nearest neighbor is
red so we'll call X red vary doesn't get
much simpler than that all right let's
try and do it now for our animals I've
blocked out this lower right-hand corner
because I want to classify these three
animals that are in gray so my training
data very smaller these animals and
these are my test set here so let's
first try and classify the zebra if we
look at the Zebras nearest neighbor well
it's either a guppy or a dart frog and
well let's just choose one let's choose
the guppy and if we look at the guppy
it's not a reptile so we say the zebra
is not a reptile
so got one right look at the Python
choose its nearest neighbor say it's a
cobra the label associated with Cobra is
reptile so we win again on the Python
alligator its nearest neighbor is
clearly a chicken and so we classify the
alligator as not a reptile oh dear
clearly the wrong answer all right what
might have gone wrong well the problem
with K nearest neighbors we can
illustrate it by looking at this example
so one of the things people do with
classifiers these days is handwriting
recognition so I just copied from a
website a bunch of numbers then I wrote
the number 40 in my own inimitable
handwriting so if we go and we look
for say the nearest neighbor of four or
sorry of whatever that digit is it is I
believe this one and sure enough that's
the row of fours we're okay on this now
if we want to classify my zero the
actual and the earth neighbor in terms
of the bitmaps if you will turns out to
be this guy a very poorly written nine I
didn't make up this nine it was it was
already there and the problem we see
here when we use nearest neighbor is if
something is noisy if you have one noisy
piece of data in this case this rather
ugly looking version of nine you can get
the wrong answer
because you match it and indeed in this
case you would get the wrong answer what
is usually done to avoid that is
something called K nearest neighbors and
the basic idea here is that we don't
just take the nearest neighbors
we take some number of nearest neighbors
usually an odd number and we just let
them vote so now if we want to classify
this fuschia X and we said k equal to
three we say well these are its three
nearest neighbors one is red two or
black so we're going to call X black is
our better guess and maybe that's
actually is a better guess because it
looks like this red point here is really
an outlier right and we don't want to
let the outliers dominate our
classification and this is why people
almost always use K nearest neighbors
rather than just nearest neighbor now if
we look at this and we use K nearest
neighbors those are the three nearest to
the first numeral and they are all fours
and if we look at the k-nearest
neighbors for the second numeral we
still have this nine but now we have two
zeros and so we vote and we decide it's
a zero is it infallible no but it's
typically much more reliable than just
nearest neighbors
hence used much more often and that was
our problem by the way with the
alligator the nearest neighbor was the
chicken but if we went back and looked
at it
maybe we should go do that and we take
the alligators three nearest neighbors
it would be the chicken the Cobra and
the rattlesnake or the boa we don't care
and we would end up correctly
classifying it now as a reptile yes
question is is real limit to how many
nearest neighbors you'd want absolutely
most obviously there's no point in
setting k equal to whoops
ooh on the rebound to the size of the
training set right so one of the
problems with K nearest neighbors is
efficiency if you're trying to find K
nearest neighbors and K is bigger it
takes longer so we worry about how big K
should be and if we make it too big and
this is a crucial thing we end up
getting dominated by the size of the
class so let's look at this picture we
had before happens to be more red dots
than black dots if I make K 10 or 15 I'm
going to classify a lot of things as red
just because red is so much more
prevalent than black and so when you
have an imbalance which you usually do
you have to be very careful about K that
makes sense
so how do you choose K remember back on
Monday when we talked about choosing K
for K means clustering we typically do a
very similar kind of thing we take our
training data and we split it into two
parts so we have we have training and
testing right now we just take the
training and we split that into training
and testing multiple times and we
experiment with different caves and we
see which cave gives us the best result
on the training data and then that
becomes our K okay and that's a very
common method it's called
cross-validation and it's for almost all
of machine learning the algorithms have
parameters in this case it's just one
parameter k and the way we typically
choose the parameter values is by
searching
through the space using this
cross-validation in the training data
that makes sense to everybody
great question and it was someone else
had a question but maybe it was the same
do you still have a question you were
using with K years
in my case three different clusters from
three different clusters well right so
if K is three and I had red black and
purple and I get one of each then what
do I do and then I'm kind of stuck so
you need to typically choose K in such a
way that when you vote you get a winner
nice so if it's to any odd number will
do if it's three well then you need
another number so that there's some but
there's always a majority right you want
to make sure that there is a winner also
a good question let's see if I get this
to you directly I'm much better at
throwing overhand I guess Wow finally
got applause for something all right
advantages and disadvantages of K and n
the learning is really fast right I just
remember everything no math is required
didn't have to show you any theory was
obviously an idea it's easy to explain
the method to somebody and the results
why did I were able with black because
that's who it was closest to the
disadvantages is its memory intensive if
I've got a million examples I have to
store them all and the predictions can
take a long time if I have an example
and I want to find its K nearest
neighbors I'm doing a lot of comparisons
right if I have a million training
points I have to compare my example to
all a million so I have no real
pre-processing overhead but each time I
need to a classification it takes a long
time now there are better algorithms
than brute force that give you
approximate K nearest neighbors but on
the whole it's still not fast and we're
not getting any information about what
process might have generated the data
right which we don't have
a model of the data in the way we say
when we did our linear regression for
curve fitting we had a model for the
data that sort of described a pattern we
don't get that out of K nearest
neighbors I'm going to show you a
different approach where we do get that
and I'm going to do it on a more
interesting example than reptiles I
apologise to those you who were rector
ologists so you probably all heard of
the Titanic there was a movie about it
I'm told it was one of the great to see
disasters of all time a so-called
unsinkable ship a hit advertised it as
unsinkable hit an iceberg and went down
the thirteen hundred passengers eight
hundred and twelve died the crew did way
worse so at least it looks as if the
crew was actually pretty heroic right
they had a higher death rate so we're
going to use machine learning to see if
we can predict which passengers survived
there's an online database I'm using it
doesn't have all 1,300 passengers but
it's information about a thousand and
forty six of them some of them they
couldn't get the information says what
cabin class they were in first second or
third how old they were and their gender
also has their name and their home
address and things which I'm not using
all right so we want to use these
features to see if we can predict which
passengers were going to survive the
disaster well the first question is
something that Professor Grimson alluded
to is is it okay just to look at
accuracy how are we going to evaluate
our machine learning and it's not if we
just predict died for everybody well
then we'll be 62% accurate for the
passengers and seventy percent seventy
six percent accurate for the crew
members usually machine learning if
you're 76 percent you say that's not bad
well here I can get that just by
predicting died so whenever you have a
class imbalance that much more of one
than of the other accuracy isn't a
particularly meaningful measure I
discovered this early on in my work in
medical area there are a lot of diseases
that rarely occur they occur and say
0.1% of the population and I can build a
great model for predicting it by just
saying nope you don't have it which will
be 0.999 percent accurate but totally
useless right and unfortunately you do
see people doing that sort of thing in
the literature all right so you saw
these in an earlier lecture just to
remind you we're going to be looking at
other metrics sensitivity think of that
as how good is it
at identifying the positive cases in
this case positive is going to be dead
how specific is it and the positive
predictive value if we say somebody died
what's the probability that they really
did and then there's a negative
predictive value if we say they didn't
die what's the probability they didn't
die so these are four very common
metrics there is something called an F
score that combines them but I'm not
going to be showing you that today I
will mention that in the literature
people often use the word recall to mean
sensitivity or sensitivity to mean
recall and specificity and precision are
used pretty much interchangeably so you
might see various combinations of these
words typically people talk about recall
and precision or sensitivity and
specificity all right that makes sense
why we want to look at the measures
other than accuracy we will look at
accuracy too and how they all tell us
kind of different things
and how you might choose a different
balance so for example if I'm running a
screening test say for breast cancer a
mammogram and trying to find the people
who should get on for a more extensive
examination what do I want to emphasize
here which of these is likely to be the
most important or what's likely to you
what would you care about most well
maybe I want sensitivity since I'm going
to send this person on for future tests
I really don't want to miss somebody who
has cancer and so I might think special
sensitivity is more important than
specificity in that particular case on
the other hand if I'm deciding who who
is so sick I should do open-heart
surgery on them maybe I want to be
pretty specific because the risks of the
surgery itself are very high I don't
want to do it on people who don't need
it and so we end up having to choose a
balance between these things depending
upon our application the other thing I
want to talk about before actually
building a classifier is how we test our
classifier because this is very
important I'm going to talk about two
different methods leave one out class
testing and repeated random subsampling
four leave one out is typically used
when you have a small number of examples
and so you want as much training data as
possible as you build your model and so
you take all of your n examples remove
one of them trained on n minus one test
on the one
you put that one back and remove another
one train on n minus one test on one and
you do this for each element of the data
and then you average your results
repeated random subsampling is done when
you have a more a larger set of data and
there you might say split your data 8020
take 80% of the data to train on test it
on 20 so this is very similar to what I
would talked about earlier and the
answer to the question about how do you
choose K right that I haven't seen the
future examples but in order to believe
in my model and say my parameter
settings I do this repeated random
subsampling or leave one out either one
so there's the code for leave one out
absolutely nothing interesting about it
so I'm not going to waste your time
looking at it repeated random
subsampling is a little more interesting
so what I've done here is I first sample
this one is just to split it 8020 it's
not doing anything repeated and I start
by sampling 20% of the indices not the
samples and I want to do that at random
I don't want to say get consecutive ones
so we do that and then once I've got the
indices I just go through and assign
each example to either test or training
and then return the two sets okay but if
I just sort of sampled one then I'd have
to do a more complicated thing to
subtract it from the other this is just
efficiency
and then here's the sorry about the
yellow there the random splits obviously
I was searching for results when I did
my screen capture so I'm just going to
arrange a number of splits I'm going to
split at 8020 it takes a parameter
method and that's interesting and we'll
see the ramifications of that later
that's going to be the machine learning
method so we're going to compare kN
to another method called logistic
regression I didn't want to have to do
this twice this code twice so I made the
method itself a parameter will see that
introduces a slight complication but
we'll get to it when we get to it so I
split it I apply whatever that method is
the training the test set I get the
results two positive false positive to
negative false negatives and then I call
this thing gets tax but I'm dividing it
by the number of splits so that will
give me the average number of true
positives the average number of false
positives etc and then I'm just going to
return them the average get stats
actually just prints a bunch of
statistics for us all right any
questions about the two methods leave
one out versus repeated random sampling
all right so let's try it for KNN on the
titanic so i'm not going to show you the
code for k-nearest classify it it's in
the code we uploaded it takes four
arguments the training set the test set
the label we're trying to classify are
we looking for the people who died or
the people who didn't die we looking for
reptiles or not reptiles or if case
there were six labels which one are we
trying to detect and
hey as in how many nearest neighbors and
then it returns the true positives the
false positives or two negatives and the
false negatives then you call we'd
already looked at lambda in a different
context
the issue here is k-nearest classify
takes four arguments yet if we go back
here for example two random splits what
we're seeing is I'm calling the method
with only two arguments because after
all if I'm not doing K nearest neighbors
maybe I don't need to pass in K right
I'm sure I don't so different methods
will take different numbers of
parameters and yet I want to use the
same function here method and so the
trick I use to get around that and this
is a very common programming trick in
math it's called currying after the
mathematician Curie not the indian dish
if i'm creating a function a new
function called KN n this will be a
function of two arguments the training
set and the test set and it will be
k-nearest classifier with training set
and test set as variables and two
constants survived and so I'm going to
predict who survived and three decay all
right
so I've been able to turn a function of
four arguments k-nearest classify into a
function of two arguments KN n by using
lambda abstraction this is something
that people do fairly frequently because
it lets you build much more general
programs when you don't have to worry
about the number of arguments so it's a
good trick to keep in your bag of tricks
again it's a trick we've used before
then I've just chosen 10 for the number
of splits
and we'll try it and we'll try it for
both methods of testing all right any
questions before I run this code
so here it is we'll run it well I should
learn how to spell finished shouldn't I
but that's okay
all right so here we have the results
and there well what can we say about
them they're not much different to start
with right so it doesn't appear that our
testing methodology had much of a
difference on how well the KNN worked
and that's actually kind of comforting
right the accurate none of the none of
the evaluation criteria are radically
different so that's kind of good
we hope that was true the other thing to
notice is that we're actually doing
considerably better than just always
predicting say didn't survive right so
we're we're doing better than a random
prediction all right let's go back now
to the PowerPoint
you're the results we don't need to
study them anymore
better than 62% accuracy but not much
difference between the experiments all
right so that's one method now let's
look at a different method and this is
probably the most common method used in
machine learning
it's called logistic regression it's in
some ways if you look at it's similar to
linear regression but different in some
important ways linear regression you
will I'm sure recall Purdue is designed
to predict a real number now what we
want here is a probability so the
probability of some event and we know
that the dependent variable can only
take on a finite set of values right so
we want to predict survived or didn't
survive it's no good to say we predict
this person half survived
you know survive but is brain dead or
something I don't know you know that's
not what we're trying to do and so the
problem with just using the regular
linear regression is a lot of time you
get nonsense predictions now you could
claim okay point five is there and it
means has a half probability of dying
not that half died but in fact if you
look at what goes on you could get more
than one out of a or less than zero out
of a linear regression and that's
nonsense when we're talking about
probabilities so we need a different
method and that's logistic regression
what logistic regression does is it
finds what are called weights for each
feature and you may recall I complained
when Professor Grimson use the word
weights to mean something somewhat
different so we take each feature for
example the gender the cabin class the
age and compute for that a weight that
we're going to use in making predictions
so think of the weights as corresponding
to the coefficients we get when we do a
linear regression
so we've now a coefficient associated
with each variable and we're going to
take those coefficients add them up and
make a you know multiply them by
something and make a prediction a
positive way implies now come back to
this later it almost implies that the
variable is positively correlated with
the outcome so we would for example say
the have scales is positively correlated
with being a reptile a negative weight
implies that the variable is negatively
correlated with the outcome so number of
legs might have a negative weight the
more legs an animal has a less light
plead is to be a reptile it's not
absolute right it's just a correlation
and the absolute magnitude is related to
the strength of the correlation so if
it's big positive it means it's a really
strong indicator if it's big negative
it's a really strong negative indicator
and then we use an optimization process
to compute these weights from the
training data it's a little bit complex
it's key is the way uses the log
function hence the name logistic but I'm
not going to make you look at it but I
will show you how to implement how to
use it so you start by importing
something called SK learn linear model
SK learn is a Python library and in that
is a class called logistic regression
it's the name of a class and here are
three methods of that class fit which
takes a sequence of feature vectors in a
sequence of labels and returns an object
of type logistic regression so this is
the place where the optimization is done
now all the examples I'm going to show
you these two sequences will be well
alright so think of this is the sequence
of feature vectors one per passenger and
the labels associated with those so this
and this have to be the same length all
right so that produces an object of this
type and then I can ask for the
coefficients which will return the
weight of each variable each feature and
then I can make a prediction
given a feature vector return the
probabilities of different labels all
right let's look at that as an example
so first let's build the model so the
Builder model will take the examples the
training data and I just said whether we
going to print something you'll notice
from this slide I've alighted the
printed stuff I will come back in a
later slide and look at what's in there
but for now I want to focus on actually
building the model so I need to create
two vectors to lists in this case the
feature vectors in the labels so for
ian's examples feature vectors dot
append I get features get label
alright couldn't be much simpler than
that and then just because it wouldn't
fit on a line of my slide I've created
this identifier called logistic
regression which is SK learned in ear
model dot logistic regression so this is
the thing I imported and this is a class
and now I'll get a model by first
creating an instance of the class
logistic regression here I'm getting an
instance and then I'll call dot fit with
that instance passing it feature of X
and labels
I now have built a logistic regression
model which is simply a set of weights
for each of the variables this makes
sense now we're going to apply the model
and I think this is the last piece of
Python I'm going to introduce this
semester case you're tired of learning
about Python and this is least list
comprehension this is how I'm going to
build my set of test feature vectors so
before we go and look at the code let's
look at how list comprehension works so
in its simplest form says sum expression
for some identifiers in some lists L it
creates a new list by evaluating this
expression len l x with the ID in the
expression replaced by each element of
the list l so let's look at a simple
example so here I'm saying l equals x
times X for X and range 10 so what's
that going to do it's going to
essentially create a list think of it as
a list or at least a sequence of values
a range type actually in Python 3 a
value 0 to 9 it will then create a list
of length 10 where the first element is
going to be 0 times 0
the second element 1 times 1 etc ok so
it's a simple way for me to create a
list looks like that I can be fancier
and say for X times L equals x times X
for X in range 10 and then I add an if
if X mod 2 is equal to 0 so now instead
of returning all building a list using
each value in range 10 it will use only
those values that satisfy that test so
we can go look at what happens when we
run that code
so you can see the first list is 1 times
1/2 times 2 cetera
and the second list is much shorter
because I'm only squaring the even
numbers what you can see that list
comprehension gives us a convenient
compact way to do certain kinds of
things like lambda expressions they're
easy to misuse right I hate reading code
where I have list comprehensions that go
over multiple lines on my screen for
example so I use it quite a lot for
small things like this if it's very
large I I find another way to do it
all right
so now we can move forward
so in applying the model I first build
my testing feature of x by e dot get
features for e in test set so that will
give me the features associated with
each element in the test set I could
obviously written a for loop to do the
same thing but this was just a little
cooler then I'm going to get model dot
predict for each of these so model dot
predict prob a is nice in that I don't
have to predict it for one example at a
time I can pass it a set of examples and
what I get back is a list of predictions
so that's just convenient then setting
these to zero and for I in range Len of
probs here a probability of 0.5 with
that saying is what I get at a logistic
regression is a probability of something
having a label I then have to to build a
classifier give a threshold and here
what I've said if the probability of it
being true is over 0.5 call it true so
if the probability of survival is over
0.5 call it survived if it's below call
it knock survived will later see that
again setting that probability is itself
an interesting thing but the default in
most systems is half for obvious reasons
okay so I get my probabilities for each
feature vector and then for I in range
lens of probabilities I'm just testing
whether the predicted label is the same
as the actual label and updating true
positives false positives true negatives
and false negatives accordingly ok so
far so good
alright let's put it all together so I'm
defining something called LR for
logistic regression
takes the training date of the test date
of the probability it builds a model and
then it gets the results by calling a
ply model with the labels survived and
whatever this problem and again we'll do
it for both leave one out and random
splits and again for ten random splits
you notice it actually runs but maybe
you won't notice but it does run faster
than KNN one of the nice thing about
logistic regression is building the
model takes a while but once you've got
the model applying it to a large number
of variables of feature vectors as fast
it's independent of the number of
training examples because we've got our
weights so solving the optimization
problem getting the weights depends upon
the number of training examples once
we've got the weights it's just
evaluating a polynomial so it's very
fast so that's a nice advantage so if we
look at those
and we should probably compare them to
our earlier K&N results so KN on the
left logistic regression on the right
and I guess if I look at it it looks
like logistic regression did a little
bit better
that's not guaranteed but it often does
outperform because it's it's more subtle
in what it does and being able to assign
different weights to different variables
so it's a little bit better that's
that's probably a good thing but there's
another reason that's really important
that people prefer logistic regression
is it provides insights about the
variables so we can look at the feature
weights so this code does that so we
remember we looked at build model and I
left out the printing well here I'm
leaving out everything except the
printing same function but leaving out
everything except the printing so we can
do model underbar classes the models dot
classes underbar gives you the classes
in this case the classes are survived
didn't survive I forget what I call that
we'll see so I can see what the classes
it's using R and then for I and Range
Len model dot Co F underbar these are
giving the weights of each veritable the
coefficients I can print what they are
so let's run that and see what we get
we get a syntax error because I turned a
comment into a line of code
all right so our model classes are died
and survived and four labels survived
what I've done by the way in the
representation is I represented the
cabin class as a binary variable either
0 or 1 because it doesn't make sense to
treat them as as if there were really
numbers right because we don't know for
example the difference between first and
second is the same as the difference
between second and third if we treated
the class we just said cabin class and
used an integer implicitly the learning
algorithm is going to assume that the
difference between 1 & 2 is the same as
between 2 & 3 if you for example look at
the prices of these cabins you'll see
that that's not true right the
difference in an airplane between
Economy Plus and economy is way smaller
than became Economy Plus and first same
thing on the Titanic but what we see
here is that for the label survived a
pretty good sized positive weight for
being in first-class cabin moderate for
being in the second and if you're in the
third class well tough luck so what we
see here is that a rich people do better
than the poor people shocking if we look
at age we'll see it's negatively
correlated what does this mean it's not
a huge weight but it basically says that
if you're older the bigger your age the
less likely you are would survive the
disaster and finally it says it's really
bad to be a male right that the men
being a male was very negatively
correlated with surviving so we see a
nice thing here is we get these labels
which we can make sense of one more
slide and then I'm done
these values are slightly different
because different randomization
different example but the main point I
want to say is you have to be a little
bit wary of reading too much into these
weights because not in this example but
in other examples well also in this
features are often correlated and if
they're correlated you run actually its
356 I'm going to explain the problem
with this on Monday when I have time to
do it properly so I'll see you then